foreign
Buffalo it's pointed East the
brightening Sky 6 52 the sunrise and
some clouds but they're moving off to
the east so we are talking about
sunshine this morning and then some more
clouds move in from the West later on
today 38 top of the hour out at
Henderson executive 44-45 over North Las
Vegas of the airport to Nellis and 40 at
Reed International in the Central Valley
winds are a calm Skies you can see
generally the clouds breaking up they're
moving Eastward we do have a generally
Clear Skies over the state under a ridge
of high pressure but that's not going to
be able to hold off one and then make it
two storms that are going to impact us
this week the first one not so much the
second one by midweek definitely 53
degrees for an afternoon high today
after morning sunshine our normal high
is 57 so we will be below normal we're
way below normal this morning about a
dozen degrees 41 for the low overnight
tonight the clouds shower possible after
mid are not likely but possible south of
the valley struggling to make it into
the 50s on the West Side mid 50s East
Side low 50s Central Valley around the
region Indian Springs 4850 in Pahrump
and 52 in both Mesquite and Boulder City
those are afternoon highs your eight day
forecast a slight chance of showers
overnight into early Tuesday and then a
better chance Thursday afternoon into
rather Wednesday afternoon into Thursday
when showers are likely and then just a
lot of clouds around going into next
weekend Nate